.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
(Radio) Die Schweiz weitet ihre
Sanktionen gegen Russland aus.
Damit schliesst sie sich
den Massnahmen der EU an.
Wohnsitz eines russischen Oligarchen
in den Bündner Bergen.
Guten Tag. Ich stehe hier vor der
Haustür von Herrn Melnitschenko.
Sind Sie da?
(Radio) Die Regierung nehme das Geld
gerne, schaue aber nicht genau hin.
Unruhe auf
dem Rohstoffhandelsplatz Zug.
Und EuroChem? Haben die bezahlt?
Aber es liegt doch nicht an uns,
an der Regierung, Polizei zu spielen
und jede Firma abzuklappern, um zu
schauen, ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Ich habe kein schlechtes Gewissen.
Die Party mit den Russen war gestern.
Jetzt geht's ans Aufräumen.
(Ueli Maurer) Der Bundesrat
übernimmt sämtliche Vorgaben der EU
und setzt sie
ins nationale Recht um.
Es gibt keine einzige Ausnahme.
Wir wollen wissen,
wie das die Schweiz macht
mit diesen Russland-Sanktionen,
und begeben uns auf Spurensuche
in Bern, Zug und St. Moritz.
Explosionen sind in der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt Kiew zu hören.
Der russische Präsident
Wladimir Putin
ordnete eine Militäraktion
in der Ukraine an.
24. Februar 2022.
Am Tag, an dem der
russische Präsident Wladimir Putin
den Krieg beginnt, bestellt er
ausgewählte Oligarchen in den Kreml.
Alles, was jetzt passiert,
war eine notwendige Massnahme.
Sie liessen uns keine andere Wahl.
Unter den 36 Oligarchen
ist auch Andrei Melnitschenko.
Melnitschenko wohnt in der Schweiz.
Und: Er hat einen Firmenhauptsitz
in der Schweiz.
Putin musste nach dem Angriff
auf die Ukraine
der russischen Öffentlichkeit
zeigen,
dass das eine gute Aktion
im Interesse Russlands ist.
Deshalb musste er aus PR-Gründen
die Oligarchen herbeibeten.
Jeder musste vor die Kamera
und sagen,
dass das gut ist und die Sanktionen
ihnen nichts machen.
Ich bin bei Thomas Borer,
ehemaliger Schweizer Botschafter,
heute Lobbyist und Berater.
Borer kennt sich aus
mit russischen Oligarchen.
Bis 2010
hat er Viktor Vekselberg beraten.
Dann habe er einen Schlussstrich
gezogen, sagt er.
Oligarchen sind abhängig von ihm.
Er macht so, und sie sind
zwei Wochen im Hausarrest.
Wenn sie dann immer noch nicht
machen, was er will,
landen sie in Sibirien.
Unter uns gesagt ist es beschämend,
dass sich bis heute
sehr viele Oligarchen nicht trauen,
sich von Putin zu distanzieren.
Das zeigt, dass sie durch und durch
abhängig von ihm sind.
Andrei Melnitschenko:
Kohleunternehmer
und einer der grössten
Düngemittelproduzenten weltweit.
Das ist
ein sehr grosses Industrieprojekt.
Viele Milliarden Dollar
werden investiert.
Und viele Arbeitsplätze geschaffen.
Der Multimilliardär ist seit dem
9. März auf der EU-Sanktionsliste.
Eine Woche später kommt er
auf die Sanktionsliste der Schweiz.
Für die EU ist klar: Weil
Melnitschenko bei Kriegsausbruch
an Putins Oligarchentreffen
teilgenommen hat,
gehört er zum engsten Wirtschafts-
kreis des russischen Präsidenten.
Die Sanktionsbehörde schreibt:
"Ferner wird daran deutlich,
dass er zu den führenden
Geschäftsleuten gehört,
die in Bereichen der Wirtschaft
tätig sind,
die der Regierung
der Russischen Föderation,
die für die Annexion der Krim
und die Destabilisierung
der Ukraine verantwortlich ist,
als wichtige Einnahmenquelle dienen."
Wir sind in den Bündner Bergen,
im Nobelkurort St. Moritz.
Hier hat Andrei Melnitschenko
offiziell seinen Hauptwohnsitz.
Am 4. August 2009
hat er dieses Haus gekauft.
Eine Villa am Suvretta-Hang.
Am Tag, als ihn die Schweiz
auf die Sanktionsliste setzt,
gehe ich zu seinem Wohnsitz.
Hallo?
Guten Tag?
Mein Name ist Kathrin Winzenried
vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Ihre Nummer ist hier angegeben.
Sie sind in Deutschland?
Und Sie sind der Haumeister?
Er arbeite seit Jahren
für die Familie Melnitschenko.
Und: Er habe für diesen Job
eine Schweigeklausel unterschrieben.
Okay. Sie dürfen wahrscheinlich
keine Auskunft erteilen?
Ob er den Lohn in diesem Monat
noch erhalten wird, weiss er nicht.
Von Angestellten anderer Oligarchen
habe er gehört,
sie hätten die Arbeit
bereits verloren.
Ich danke Ihnen herzlich
und wünsche alles Gute.
Auf Wiederhören.
Andrei Melnitschenko gehört zu
den wenigen russischen Oligarchen,
die auf der Sanktionsliste stehen
und in der Schweiz Wohnsitz haben.
Eine Handvoll
ist bis jetzt öffentlich bekannt.
In St. Moritz ist Melnitschenko einer
von rund 100 Pauschalbesteuerten.
Wie häufig er hier oben ist,
bleibt unklar.
Das eines der wenigen Fotos
von ihm in St. Moritz:
Besuch einer privaten Cocktailparty
in der Galerie Gmurzynska.
Zufällig treffen wir vor Ort
eine Frau, die Melnitschenko kennt:
ein Hausangestellte, die
bei einer anderen Familie arbeitet.
Manchmal
sehe ich sie auf der Strasse.
Manchmal veranstalten sie
auch Partys und Diners.
Was man von aussen sieht,
ist nicht das, was es wirklich ist:
Viel versteckt sich im Berg.
Viele Räume, Spas, solche Dinge.
Warum wissen Sie das?
Weil ich die Angestellten kenne.
Es gibt Leute, die das ganze Jahr
hier sind und den Unterhalt machen,
so wie ich.
Wenn die Besitzer kommen,
bringen sie das Personal mit.
Das Personal kommt mit?
Ja, das ganze Team.
Küchenpersonal, Babysitter,
Putzequipe, Skilehrer, Taxi, Butler.
Ungefähr zum Zeitpunkt
der Filmaufnahmen
meldet das Bündner Grundbuchamt
die Liegenschaft in Bern:
Vermögenswert
eines sanktionierten Oligarchen,
der von Amtes wegen
eingefroren werden muss.
Doch was heisst eingefroren?
Thomas Borer erklärt.
In aller Regel ist es so,
dass man ein Wohnhaus
mit der Familie weiter benutzt.
Man darf die Ausgaben des normalen
Unterhalts des Hauses tätigen.
Aber man muss immer eine Bewilligung
bei der Sanktionsbehörde einholen,
damit die Bank
die Zahlungen tätigen kann.
Wenn es ein Flugzeug
oder ein Schiff ist,
gehört das nicht
zum normalen Lebensunterhalt.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das im
Ausland nicht mehr bewilligt wird.
Die Schweiz sollte die Benutzung
davon nicht mehr bewilligen.
Die Guardia di Finanza -
die italienische Finanzpolizei -
zeigt medienwirksam vor,
wie man's macht:
Die teuerste Segeljacht der Welt
wird am Freitag, 11. März,
im Hafen von Triest dichtgemacht.
Ihr Besitzer: Der Oligarch
aus St. Moritz, Andrei Melnitschenko.
Melnitschenko Luxusschiff
mit einer Länge von 143 m
und einem Wert
von rund 500 Mio. ¤
wird wohl für lange Zeit
seeuntauglich bleiben.
In der Schweiz
hat der russische Oligarch
zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch freie Hand:
Die Eidgenossen hinken
den EU-Sanktionen massiv hinterher.
Auf Putin hat das keine Wirkung.
Aber auf den individuellen
Oligarchen eine verheerende Wirkung.
Diese Leute sind es gewohnt,
Macht auszuüben.
Über Milliarden zu verfügen.
Grosse Geschäfte zu tätigen.
Auf schönen Jachten zu leben.
Das können sie alles nicht mehr.
Das waren noch Zeiten:
russischer Silvester
an der Zürcher Bahnhofstrasse.
Gastgeberin:
die Hoteldirektorin Ljuba Manz.
* Sie spricht russisch. *
Man muss das Glas bis zum Rand
füllen, es auf ex austrinken
und es wegwerfen.
D.h., dass man das Leben bis
zum letzten Tropfen geniessen soll.
Und dann die Hülle
einfach abstreifen.
Manz ist gebürtige Ukrainerin.
Gefeiert wurde an ihren Anlässen
aber stets Russland.
Und die Schweizer High Society
feierte gerne mit.
Im Moment hoffen wir
auf sibirische Kälte,
damit der St. Moritzersee zufriert,
sodass wir das Poloturnier
gut durchführen können.
Jetzt, wo die Party vorbei ist,
hätten wir gerne mit Ljuba Manz
über die Sanktionen gegen Russland
gesprochen,
um zu erfahren,
was sie davon hält.
Sie habe kein Interesse an einem
Interview, liess sie ausrichten.
Auch am Zürcher Paradeplatz ist
Russland derzeit ein heikles Thema,
namentlich bei der Credit Suisse.
Die hat russischen Oligarchen
in der Vergangenheit geholfen,
ihre Privatflugzeuge und Jachten
zu finanzieren.
Das hat die britische "Financial
Times" kürzlich aufgedeckt.
Der Journalist Robert Smith
staunte nicht schlecht,
als ihm Hedge-Fonds-Manager
berichteten,
die Credit Suisse habe versucht,
ihnen ein Finanzprodukt anzudrehen,
in dem die CS Kredite
für Jachten und Privatflugzeuge
zusammengefasst hatte.
Die Präsentation für die Investoren
zeigt Schwarz auf Weiss:
dass die Credit Suisse
russischen Oligarchen geholfen hat,
ihre Jets und Jachten
zu finanzieren.
Bei der Credit Suisse ist die
Enthüllung der "Financial Times"
offenbar schlecht angekommen.
Kurz darauf passierte Folgendes:
Russland hat mit der Invasion
der Ukraine begonnen,
was uns alle schockierte.
In der Woche darauf
hörte ich sehr seltsame Dinge.
Einige Investoren,
auf die die Credit Suisse
im Zusammenhang mit diesem Deal
zugegangen ist,
bekamen plötzlich Briefe
von der Credit Suisse.
Da stand drin: "Wir fordern Sie auf,
alle Dokumente,
die wir Ihnen gegeben haben,
dauerhaft zu löschen."
Die Credit Suisse sagt,
die Aufforderung zur Aktenvernichtung
sei ein ganz normaler Vorgang.
Intern seien die Daten
noch vorhanden.
Keiner, mit dem ich gesprochen habe,
konnte sich erinnern,
dass eine Bank
je solche Briefe verschickt hat,
dass Dokumente
dauerhaft vernichtet werden sollten.
Für die Bank
ist es eine sehr sensible Zeit.
Darum will sie
über ihre Geschäfte mit Oligarchen
so wenig wie möglich bekanntgeben.
Mit den Sanktionen sitzt die USA
dem Schweizer Finanzplatz im Nacken.
Es gibt auch Dinge, die legal sind,
aber trotzdem kritisiert werden.
Ein Problem
des Finanzplatzes Schweiz ist,
dass er nicht nur Oligarchen,
sondern auch anderen Vermögenden
hilft,
mit Schachtelstrukturen,
mit vielen Firmengründungen
in anderen Staaten,
z.B. Panama und Bermuda,
den eigentlichen Eigentümer,
den wirtschaftlich Berechtigten
zu verstecken.
(Ueli Maurer) Insbesondere
interessieren die Sanktionen
im Finanzbereich.
Ich gehe etwas näher darauf ein:
Im Finanzbereich ist es für die
Schweiz von zentralem Interesse,
dass die Integrität des Finanz-
platzes Schweiz gewährleistet ist.
Bundesrat Maurer sagte:
Russische Kundengelder figurierten
in der Schweizer Vermögensbranche
unter ferner liefen.
Später wurde die Zahl konkret:
Immerhin:
Rund 200 Mrd. ¤ aus Russland
liegen bei Schweizer Banken - ein
grosser Teil davon Oligarchengeld.
Doch: Wie gut sind die Schweizer,
wenn es jetzt ums Jagen
von solchen Vermögenswerten geht?
Kollege Simon Christen ist unterwegs
an der Baarerstrasse in Zug,
einer Drehscheibe
für russische Rohstoffe.
Hier reiht sich
Briefkasten an Briefkasten.
Nicht wenige davon
von Rohstofffirmen.
Wie z.B. EVRAZ -
ein Stahl- und Bergbaukonzern,
an dem Roman Abramovich
beteiligt ist.
Oder die inzwischen zahlungsunfähige
AG Nord Stream 2.
Die Finanzdirektion des Kantons Zug
ist ebenfalls an besagter
Baarerstrasse zu Hause.
Wir haben einen Termin
beim verantwortlichen Regierungsrat.
Hallo, Christen
vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
(Frau) Ich öffne Ihnen.
- Danke.
Ich will vom Finanzdirektor wissen,
was er bisher unternommen hat
in Bezug auf sanktionierte Firmen
und Personen.
Es ist nicht
unsere oder meine Aufgabe,
mich mit diesen Listen
auseinanderzusetzen
und denen unter die Arme zu greifen.
Die Sanktionen sind da.
Sanktionen treffen immer alle.
Laut SECO müssen Sie Vermögenswerte
erheben und melden.
Muss ich das?
Ja. Die Kantone
müssten das jetzt machen.
Ich habe keinen Brief dazu erhalten.
Wir haben nichts bekommen. Sie sind
jetzt nicht hier. Nicht reinreden!
Tännler holt für uns intern
den letzten Stand ab.
Sorry, Guido,
wenn ich nochmals störe. Eine Frage:
Diese Sanktionen,
die gegen die Ukraine laufen ...
Ist vom SECO
eine Aufforderung gekommen,
dass wir Vermögenswerte von Firmen
erheben müssen,
die möglicherweise pleite gehen
wie EuroChem wegen Melnitschenko
usw. Hast du etwas erhalten?
Wir haben nichts erhalten.
Dann wäre das
in der Volkswirtschaftsdirektion?
Ich habe nie etwas erhalten.
Danke dir.
Tschüss.
* Er lacht. *
Wir fragen
bei der Sanktionsbehörde SECO nach.
Das SECO schreibt uns,
die Meldepflicht gelte auch
ohne vorgängige Information
durch die Schweizer Behörde.
Einfacher gesagt als getan.
Bei der Steuerverwaltung im Kanton
Graubünden gibt es Unklarheiten.
Müssen Vermögenswerte
des sanktionierten Melnitschenko,
die nur in den Steuerunterlagen
ersichtlich sind, gemeldet werden?
Selbstverständlich halten wir
uns als kantonale Steuerverwaltung
an diese Verordnung.
Das Problem ist aber:
Es ist nicht klar, Stand heute,
wie diese Verordnung auszulegen ist.
Oder anders gesagt:
Es steht überhaupt nicht fest,
ob die Steuerverwaltungen
von dieser Meldepflicht
bzw. von dieser Verordnung
des Bundes auch betroffen sind.
Wir haben schliesslich
ein Steuergeheimnis.
Im Kanton Graubünden
ist das sehr strikt.
Und jetzt gilt es,
das Spannungsverhältnis zwischen
dem Steuergeheimnis einerseits
und einer allfälligen Meldepflicht
gestützt auf diese Bundesverordnung
andererseits, zu prüfen
und dann zu entscheiden.
Bei der Sanktionsbehörde SECO gibt es
zu dieser Frage keine klare Aussage.
Ich frage mehrmals nach und
erhalte schliesslich die Antwort,
die Steuerbehörden
seien je nach Fall meldepflichtig.
Mit anderen Worten:
Das SECO lässt die Kantone hängen.
An der Baarerstrasse in Zug
treffen Schweizer Behörden,
Firmen mit Russland-Bezug
und deren hochspezialisierten Anwälte
aufeinander.
z.B. EuroChem und SUEK.
Beide bis vor Kurzem kontrolliert
von Andrei Melnitschenko,
dem Oligarchen aus dem Bündnerland.
Sanktionen gegen solche Firmen
werden jetzt gefordert.
Es gibt nicht nur Kritik
aus dem Kanton.
Auch international
gibt es Kritik am Kanton Zug.
Es heisst z.B.: "Business as usual
für russische Firmen im Kanton Zug."
"Bloomberg" schreibt das:
Stimmt das?
Nein, wir machen nicht einfach
business as usual.
Wir erfüllen
unsere Aufgaben korrekt,
bei unserer Zuständigkeit
und in unserem Einflussbereich.
Aussenpolitik macht der Bund.
Das macht nicht der Kanton Zug.
Was ist in dieser Frage
die Zuständigkeit Ihrer Direktion?
In welcher Frage?
Im Zusammenhang mit den Sanktionen.
Wie werden die umgesetzt?
Wir haben unseren Aufgabenkatalog,
den wir erfüllen.
Wenn wir vom Bund ...
- Was umfasst der?
Wie?
Jetzt gehen Sie zu weit.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun.
Sie müssen nicht mich
in der Finanzdirektion
nach meinem Aufgabenkatalog fragen.
Ich halte mich an die Gesetze.
Das erwarte ich auch von
meinen Mitarbeitern und Ämtern.
Ich halte mich an die Standards.
Wenn Sanktionen vom Bund verfügt
werden, setzen wir die um. Punkt.
Am 9. März kommt Andrei Melnitschenko
auf die Sanktionsliste der EU.
Am gleichen Tag zieht er sich aus
seinen beiden Firmen EuroChem
und SUEK zurück
und verkauft Aktienanteile.
Nur mit seinem Rückzug kann
der Betrieb aufrechterhalten werden.
Doch wo ist das Geld,
das der Oligarch
aus dem Aktienverkauf löste?
Die Schweizer Behörden
kümmert das nicht.
Beim Bund kommt er erst eine Woche
später auf die Sanktionsliste.
Darum sei man nicht zuständig,
sagt das SECO.
Und auch der Kanton Zug
weiss von nichts.
Darüber ist uns nichts bekannt.
Vielleicht ist der zuständigen
Person in der Steuerverwaltung
mehr bekannt.
Auch hier muss ich sagen:
Ich muss nicht recherchieren
und Detektivarbeit leisten.
Das ergibt sich automatisch,
was dort passiert.
Diese Informationen
muss ich nicht im Detail kennen.
Ich sehe im Moment
keinen konkreten Handlungsbedarf.
Ich würde zuwarten
und nichts überstürzen
mit einem Überaktionismus.
Jetzt muss man die Krise
Krise sein lassen und schauen,
wie sie sich international
entwickelt.
Wenn man am Horizont
wieder Licht sieht,
dann muss man wie bei jeder Krise
am Ende überlegen, analysieren
und schauen,
ob man nachjustieren muss.
Gerne hätten wir vor der Kamera
mit der Sanktionsbehörde SECO
über diese Suche nach Geld
und Vermögenswerten gesprochen -
doch das Bundesamt winkt ab.
Die Belastung fürs Personal
sei derzeit zu gross.
Die Behörde schreibt uns allgemein,
das SECO habe sich
für eine Meldepflicht
und gegen eine Jagd
auf Vermögenswerte entschieden.
Das SECO sei keine Finanzpolizei.
Um die Sanktionen umzusetzen,
habe man eine kleine Taskforce
eingerichtet.
Ich treffe Mark Pieth,
emeritierter Strafrechtsprofessor
und Geldwäschereiexperte.
Er kann die zögerliche Art des SECO
nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass ein Land,
das eine derartige Verantwortung
hat, gerade mit Russland,
in der Lage sein muss,
zu reagieren.
Sanktionen sind nichts Neues.
Seit der Krim-Annexion
haben wir Sanktionen gegen Russen.
Das ist eine eingespielte Sache.
Man muss wissen, wie es läuft.
Und wenn eine oder zwei Personen
zuständig sind,
dann ist das
eine Frage von Inkompetenz.
Das SECO sagt,
sie hätten sieben Tage gebraucht
für die Adaption der EU-Verordnung
an die Schweizer Verordnung.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Das ist enorm schädlich
für den Ruf der Schweiz.
Es ist vielleicht schlimmer,
es ist vielleicht auch eine Taktik,
die es Leuten ermöglichen soll, noch
ihr Geld ins Trockene zu bringen.
Die Rätsel ums Geld
von Andrei Melnitschenko
aus seinen Aktienverkäufen
bleibt ungelöst.
Die offizielle Schweiz
interessiert sich nicht dafür.
Der Betroffene Andrei Melnitschenko
äussert sich dazu nicht.
In St. Moritz sind die Sanktionen ein
Thema, doch lieber nicht öffentlich.
Erstaunlich,
denn in der Vergangenheit
war die Verbindung zu Russland
nie ein Problem.
* Schneller werdende,
traditionelle russische Musik *
Die gehen in den Urlaub,
die wollen sich Gutes tun,
die wollen Geld ausgeben,
Spass haben.
Entsprechend sind sie auch bereit,
etwas dafür zu bezahlen.
Hotels, Lokale, Leute, die mit
den Russen arbeiten, profitieren.
Die Russen
sind für uns sehr wichtig.
Etwa 150 Skilehrer
sind in dieser Zeit
mit russischen Gästen unterwegs.
Russen, die hier in St. Moritz sind,
sind sehr wertschöpfungsintensiv.
Russenpflaster
nennt man St. Moritz auch.
Darum möchte ich
vom Gemeindepräsidenten wissen,
welche Auswirkungen
die Sanktionen auf den Kurort haben.
Doch der winkt ab.
Er, der nie
um einen Spruch verlegen ist
und sich auf der Internetseite
der Gemeinde so präsentiert:
Christian Jott Jenny.
Ich bin Gemeindepräsident
von St. Moritz,
das ist das Oval Office: die
Arvenstube der Gemeindeverwaltung.
Von hier aus wird alles kommandiert,
kontrolliert und regiert.
Das macht Spass.
Der sonst so kommunikative
Gemeindepräsident
reagiert auf unsere Anfrage
mit einer dürren E-Mail.
"Das Verhältnis russischer Gäste
ist in unserer Gemeinde
vernichtend klein - rund 2,3 %."
"Es gibt für uns deshalb keinen Grund
zur Sorge resp. der Kommunikation."
"Ich bitte Sie um Verständnis."
Ich rufe ihn an.
Herr Jenny,
wir sind in St. Moritz.
Wo sind Sie denn?
Sie nehmen keine Stellung,
ob Sie das politisch richtig finden?
Sämtliche Gemeinden des Oberengadins
hätten entschieden,
die Sanktionen und deren Auswirkungen
nicht öffentlich zu kommentieren,
sagt mir Christian Jott Jenny.
Tatsächlich sind die Logiernächte
russischer Gäste
in St. Moritz zurückgegangen
in den letzten Jahren.
Gemäss Statistik
des Kantons Graubünden
konsumieren sie allerdings
nach wie vor weit mehr
als der Schweizer Durchschnittsgast.
Ich treffe Silvia Affolter,
ehemalige Miss Schweiz
und heute Unternehmerin.
Wer will Espresso, wer will Kaffee?
Silvia Affolter
ist bestens vernetzt in St. Moritz.
Seit zwei Jahren
wohnt sie auch im Oberengadin.
Natürlich selbst gemacht.
Von ihr will ich wissen,
warum das mit den Sanktionen
hier oben so ein heikles Thema ist.
Wir leben natürlich
von den Touristen,
wir leben von reichen Touristen.
Es ist nicht
irgendein billiges Pflaster.
Das spüre ich heraus.
Es ist der Frust,
dass die Schweiz sich erlaubt,
Sanktionen durchzuführen,
Kreditkarten einfach einzufrieren.
Dass die Leute
nicht mehr zahlungsfähig sind,
das verstehen sie nicht.
Und sie fragen sich:
Wer ist dann als Nächster dran?
Sind es vielleicht die Saudis
oder die italienische Mafia?
Wer bestimmt dann überhaupt,
was das für Leute sind?
Wer hat Blutgeld an den Händen?
Sie befürwortet
die Sanktionen gegen Russland.
Man müsse alles Menschenmögliche
unternehmen,
Leid und Elend in der Ukraine
möglichst schnell zu stoppen.
Und dann
erzählt sie mir noch eine Geschichte,
die da oben derzeit die Runde macht.
Ein Russe wollte offenbar bei Armani
seine Rechnung begleichen
über 22'000 Fr, nicht gerade wenig.
Die Kreditkarte war gesperrt.
Da Armani
gerade selbst in St. Moritz war,
rief der Geschäftsführer gleich
Giorgio Armani persönlich an
und fragte, was los sei.
Armani sagte,
dass das ein langjähriger Kunde sei,
den könne man
nicht einfach stehen lassen.
Man solle ihm seine Ware
ohne Bezahlung mitgeben,
man schaue dann später.
Gekappter Zahlungsverkehr
in St. Moritz:
bis dato ein unbekanntes
und unvorstellbares Problem.
Russengeld ist derzeit auch
in Zug das Thema Nummer 1.
Z.B. bei Anastasia Gilli, die
an der Baarerstrasse ihr Büro hat.
Die gebürtige Russin
bietet seit zwölf Jahren
einen exklusiven Service
für reiche Russen:
Sie organisiert den Umzug
in die Schweiz -
vom Aushandeln
einer Pauschalbesteuerung
über die Suche nach einer Immobilie
bis zur Privatschule für die Kinder.
Seit der Krieg in der Ukraine
begonnen habe,
sei in Zug alles anders, sagt sie.
Ihr Geschäft stehe still.
Und als Russin halte sie sich
zurück bei Diskussionen.
Mit meinen ukrainischen Freundinnen
rede ich lieber nicht
über das Thema Politik.
Wieso nicht?
Es ist sehr schmerzhaft für sie -
auch für mich.
Es ist ein sehr heikles Thema.
Wer sich als Russin zu erkennen gebe,
sei derzeit Anfeindungen ausgesetzt.
Das höre sie immer wieder
von ihren Kunden -
sogar die Kinder würden angegangen.
Ich hörte von meinen Kunden, dass
einige Tage nach Kriegsausbruch
ihre Kinder von anderen Kindern
in der Schule beschimpft wurden.
Weil sie Russen sind.
Weil Putin einen Krieg
angefangen hat.
Die Kinder haben natürlich
gar nichts damit zu tun.
Aber kleine Kinder wissen das nicht.
Sie hören nur,
was die Erwachsenen sagen.
Anastasia Gilli
hat von den Eltern dieser Kinder
in den letzten Jahren
sehr gut gelebt:
von Russen,
die wegwollten aus Russland.
Mit dem Problem von Scheinwohnsitzen
sei sie kaum je konfrontiert worden.
Ich kann nicht sagen, dass alle
zu 100 % in der Schweiz wohnen.
Sie haben Familien,
die sie besuchen,
sie haben weltweit Business.
Sie müssen reisen.
Dass man nur eine Adresse in der
Schweiz hat, aber dort nicht wohnt,
das hatten meine Kunden nie.
Sie schätzen die Schweiz, die Natur,
alles, was die Schweiz bietet.
Das schätzen sie sehr.
Ich würde nicht sagen,
dass meine Kunden
nur der Adresse wegen hier sind.
Glauben Sie das oder sind Sie sicher?
Gehen wir dorthin?
- Ja.
* Sie seufzt. *
Fragen Sie mich etwas anderes.
Ob Zug seine Anziehungskraft
für reiche Russen bewahren kann,
ist laut Gilli offen.
Dass die Schweiz nun
Firmen und Personen sanktioniere,
sei bei ihr sehr schlecht angekommen.
Die Schweiz ist nicht mehr neutral.
Vorher war es
eine sichere Oase der Neutralität.
Die Leute wussten,
dass man darauf vertrauen konnte.
Das ist nicht mehr so.
Auch die Regierung könnte von heute
auf morgen dein Konto einfrieren.
Man hat keinen Zugang mehr.
Das verändert Dinge
und bleibt im Kopf.
Noch einmal in St. Moritz:
Château Papillon Charity-Dinner
für die Ukraine.
Looks amazing.
Eine Auktion steht auf dem Programm:
Kunstwerke einer aus der Ukraine
geflüchteten Künstlerin
werden versteigert.
Der Erlös des Abends
geht an Hilfswerke.
Der Anlass steht unter Motto:
St. Moritz kann auch anders -
St. Moritz helps.
Es kann doch nicht sein,
dass wir die ganze Zeit Milliardären
hinterherrennen.
Nur weil die ...
- Das interessiert mich nicht.
Mich interessiert nur
das Geld auf meinem Konto.
Das ist so.- Aber jetzt musst du
hier ein Kunstwerk kaufen, Vera.
Das würde gut
in deine Wohnung passen.
Wir können nachher schauen.
Schauen Sie,
was in der Ukraine passiert.
Wir müssen schon etwas machen.
Und ...
Jetzt ändert sich das halt.
Dann kommen halt andere.
Die Geld haben, meinst du?
- Dann kommen andere Kriminelle.
Vorher hatte es Araber.
- Ja, genau, dann kommen wieder die.
Jetzt sind es die Russen.
- Ist doch egal.
Ein bunter Gäste-Mix aus
Alteingesessenen und Zugezogenen
kommt an diesem Abend zusammen.
Wir sind eigentlich neutral.
Das wird von uns auch verlangt.
Deshalb ist es sehr schwierig,
Partei zu ergreifen.
Die Konflikte existieren nicht seit
gestern, sondern seit Jahrhunderten.
40'000 Fr.
werden an diesem Abend gesammelt
und gehen in die Ukraine.
Andrei Melnitschenko, der Besitzer
dieses Hauses, ist weit weg,
ausserhalb des Sanktionsgebietes.
In die Schweiz einreisen
kann er nicht mehr.
Er werde
den Sanktionsentscheid anfechten,
schreibt einer seiner Sprecher
Melnitschenko habe keinen Bezug
zu den tragischen Ereignissen
in der Ukraine.
Er sei für den Frieden.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
D. Zacheo, M. Hoss - 2022